we're back with the wonderful
effervescent and extraordinary neil
patrick harris and his husband david
burka
david is here i pulled him in hey
david i just have to say that thanks one
person clapped that was exciting
we listen to this we well we're we're
very paired down over here
oh there we go literally
people think you think people make fun
of me they're like she's alone in a big
room like doing her own thing i'm like
no i swear we have
i have some people here um the wonderful
crew david i really just have to say
thank you again
because you are so near and dear to my
heart i had a really bad flight with my
kids
and um they were both acting out you
know
two years old and three years old and
you're always that person on the plane
that's just so horrified that you're
the one ruining everyone else's flight
and you told me
you were like i've been through it too
this is normal
you're doing a good job it's okay try to
take like the stress out of your body
people aren't as upset as you probably
are projecting that they are
and you changed my life that day because
i
flew with my children everywhere all the
time i took them
all over the place and you changed
flying for me because i was always so
stressed and embarrassed so
thank you so happy yeah because we've
all been there right we've
all been there yes and you just went you
had that crying and you think you're
you're just
horrified that you have this crying
child that everybody's looking at you
but
i'm so glad you got through it well you
did it with ease
thank you david and i love your
entertainment lifestyle
books i just think you're so amazing and
uh you contribute so much to the world
and you contributed to one parent that
was
really freaking out and it's you know
it's just hard to be a parent with two
kids and
you know you just want to make it kind
of okay for everyone else and
weirdly not many people are making it
okay for you
in that moment and that's what you did
and i will never forget it for the rest
of my life
and in fact i will always pay it forward
my pleasure my pleasure i'm so happy to
help you that day
yeah very nice yeah no and you guys are
just awesome parents and i love watching
you with your kids
and it's so spiritual speaking of um
where are the
kids the kids
[Laughter]
and that was an hour neil you and i were
both children in the spotlight
and both children of the 80s and
there's like a certain gal that i'm
excited to welcome
back to the show she's also a one in the
spotlight and of the 80s take a look
i know she's an icon of peanut
and after bursting onto the scene please
welcome
courtney she spent time with tastemakers
dignitaries
and the simply divine meal patrick
harris
but she's not just an international
superstar
she's an incredible friend and always
knows what to say
this is courtney
ladies and gentlemen courtney
corny got more applause than my husband
absolutely not we love david and you
grew up in the spotlight
do you have any words of wisdom for
courtney
um yeah of course courtney hi um
listen i do have a few things to say
courtney i know
that all of this seems um seems fun now
you know the the parties the fame
and that's because it is it's it's fun
but
but fame is fleeting there is however
one thing that will always be there for
you and do you know what that is
right courtney money so start saving
those pennies
and get those royalty checks because
you're going to need them when your
one-woman show tanks and your agent
skips town to go to a spa in jackson
hole
courtney listen to neil
i was once like you young wide-eyed
and born in a doll factory and the 80s
are great
but you know what else is great becoming
an adult
wait courtney let me finish
you need to hear this when you grow up
you can be an
actor a singer a magician or any one of
the other
thousand things neil does so just you
wait courtney you've got a big life
ahead of you
and who knows maybe you too could be
hosts
like neil and i we're getting paid for
this right
neal's right save your money yes
thanks neil i think that we've done a
tremendous service today
i really do too and i feel like she hurt
us i feel like she really got us
maybe maybe she can be like us
child actors who have grown up and
and and and and we're we're doing good
that's that's the bottom line life is
good
um neil patrick harris
you are the most amazing gentleman
and i'm just so glad you were on the
show today it was such a privilege
so much fun to hang out with you i think
we saved a life
and i saved a life and we informed a lot
of people about
a great holiday gift just saying first
of all it's going in the weekender
i'm this is this game is everything
everybody run out it is the most
intelligent unique
special inventive game you are going to
freak out
it is just beyond words and you make me
a single promise that when you finish
box one
you will you will tell me what you
thought of it at the end of the
experience because
you're saying these wonderful things and
you haven't even finished the game which
i which makes me beyond excited
and it's a challenge like it's really
really it's
it's just so great and i absolutely will
follow through by the way right before i
get out of here i just have to tell you
your performance in hedwig is one of my
favorite ever
in life and i will never forget seeing
you in that show
and you won the tony and it was so well
deserved your performance was like none
other
and box one is available exclusively at
target stores and online
right now we'll be right back neil
patrick
[Music]
you